when you walk around Yale's campus you
can see the evidence of historic
investment in engineering they granted
the first engineering PhD I'm in the
incredibly fortunate position of being
asked to lead a School of Engineering at
a moment of transition what we've seen
across the university landscape is
increasing investment just in basic
student facilities what I think has been
lagging a little bit behind find is the
investment in infrastructure spaces for
academic collaboration for creative
technology work maker spaces Computing
facilities where students can get
together and work on coding projects we
recognize that to build an engineering
school of the prominent scale needs we
needed to grow 30 new faculty slots were
allocated to engineering this will be a
growth of 50% of the size of the
engineering faculty we are building new
spaces to support support their activity
we're building in a way that engages our
excellence in medicine our excellence in
biology our excellence in economics and
political science but engineering will
be the center of it and it has to be the
challenges in the world that we Face are
engineering challenges as we think about
the new spaces we'll be creating in
lower
Hillhouse we want to have First Rate top
tier laboratory infrastructure
that will surround and be engaged with
the undergraduate life we imagine spaces
that will serve as Innovation spaces for
commercialization opportunities for new
startups spaces that will welcome
industry Partners to come interact with
faculty and
[Music]
students something is changing here and
Yale is in a position to make good on
its promise to improve the world for
today and for future Generations
[Music]